il n'est pas candidat mais il l'aimait
tous au pas ou plutôt opaque Beyrou
buffet Sarkozy royal voanais en toute
dix prétendants à l'Élysée avait répondu
ce matin à l'appel de Nicolas Hulot ils
ont tous signé devant les caméras son
pacte écolo et pris des engagements pour
mettre l'environnement au cœur de leur
action anne-charline
ciel mission accomplie pour Nicolas
Hulot au bas de son pacte écologique 10
signatures celles de 10 prétendants à
l'Élysée les candidats de tout bord ont
répondu présent à son appel 15 minutes
montre en main ils se sont pliés à
l'exercice imposé évoqué à la tribune
leur engagement pour l'écologie
l'excellence environnementale que je
veux porter n'est pas un slogan ce n'est
pas une annonce circonstancielle c'est
un engagement à agir avec détermination
et courage sous l'oeil de Nicolas Hulot
les candidats tentent de convaincre tous
se disent prêts à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique à revoir les
politiques de transport de l'énergie et
de l'agriculture même si certains
affichent leurs différences il suffit
pas que vous demandiez pour obtenir il
suffit pas que vous disiez pour
convaincre c'est un dialogue c'est un
échange c'est un respect mutuel vous
avez vos préoccupations votre expérience
chez la mienne j'ai le devoir de parler
aussi à des millions de Français dernier
à passer son grand oral Nicolas Sarkozy
n'aura croisé aucun autre candidat la
signature du Pacte écologique n'a pas
prêté au débat juste des promesses ce
soir sur notre antenne Nicolas Hulot
voulait les croire sincères j'ai du mal
à imaginer que sur un enjeu aussi
univers el fondamental qui met en péril
l'avenir de l'humanité on puisse
s'affranchir chemin faisant d'engagement
qui ont été fait ce matin pas face à moi
mais devant les Français plus candidat
mais toujours dans la bataille
présidentielle Nicolas Hulot réussit son
tour de force rendre l'écologie
incontournable